es la primera visita de estado de un
presidente francés a los Países Bajos en
23 años además de ceremonia y protocolo
habrá asuntos que tratar en el centro de
las conversaciones la soberanía europea
Emmanuel macrón aprovecha la ocasión
para presentar su visión de la seguridad
económica del continente la autonomía
estratégica debe ser una prioridad para
Europa no queremos depender de otros en
cuestiones críticas cuando ya no podamos
elegir en materia de energía o sobre las
formas de defendernos en lo que respecta
a los medios sociales y la Inteligencia
artificial Porque no tenemos la
infraestructura necesaria estaremos
fuera de la historia por un tiempo
Francia y Países Bajos antaños situados
en extremos Opuestos del espectro
europeo en materia de gastos social se
han acercado desde el inicio de la
guerra contra Ucrania el líder francés
quiere persuadir a sus homólogos
europeos en particular al Primer
Ministro holandés Mark rute para que
invierten masivamente en energías
limpias en medio de la preocupación por
la subvenciones verdes de Estados Unidos
bajos es también un actor clave en la
industria mundial de alta tecnología es
uno de los tres únicos países del mundo
que tiene una cadena de valor de
semiconductores completa Los Microchips
están en el centro de la estrategia de
la Unión Europea para reducir su
dependencia de China y Estados Unidos la
próxima semana los 27 miembros del
bloque tienen previsto aprobar la ley
Europea de chips diseñada para fomentar
el desarrollo de la industria de
semiconductores en Europa con unos 43
mil millones de dólares de inversiones
públicas y privadas el bloque aspira a
duplicar la capacidad de producción de
chips hasta alcanzar el 20% del
suministro mundial procede también
quiere impulsar la inversión en
computadores cuánticos macron tiene
previsto firmar un pacto por la
innovación bilateral durante su visita